my cesarean was on the friday wow
i'm still emailing everyone in the
morning
how have you gone about maintaining your
career aspirations as well as your
personal family aspirations as well yeah
okay so
it's always family first
it's really tough but you know what if i
didn't have a family you can't tell me
that people who don't have families also
have easy lives again like you just
can't judge anyone until you're in their
shoes so yeah i've had two kids even
just like being pregnant you know was
difficult i was really lucky i didn't
have any qualms telling anybody i think
at the time i was a regional director um
just communicated it okay i did only
take six months off so i say only that
was a personal choice of mine i was
really passionate about the brand like
digital gurus hadn't existed in the
north and that was like my baby at the
time so taking that time out and having
my son it was really weird right so i
had a caesarean which meant it was a
planned caesarean so i worked until the
thursday my cesarean was on the friday
i was still emailing everyone in the
morning and i'm just like still in work
mode so that was weird but that's my
personality right so and it took a
little while to kind of switch off
because then the baby is there and they
need you like fully the recruitment
mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by
vincerie and the award-winning sauce
breaker